what's going on guys in the juicy kaizen
manga the cullen games is an upcoming
fight to the death involving both
sorcerers and non-sorcerers from all
across japan while there are a ton of
rules surrounding this massacre the main
thing you need to know is that it was
organized by kanjaku who wants to use
the cullen games as a ritual to forcibly
evolve humanity this ritual is estimated
to last two months and it will use the
player's cursed energy to begin merging
the people of japan with tengen who is
an immortal character that is over one
thousand years old if humans were to
evolve in this way then evil would
spread across the planet and life as we
know would cease to exist so the cullen
games definitely has the biggest stakes
of the series so far there are so many
possibilities for how it could go down
and with me today to give our 100
guaranteed to happen predictions is
shonen so tell me how do you feel about
that percentage
uh maybe you know take it down a point
one or or just a whole one maybe
ninety-nine percent is maybe more
accurate yeah that nine-nine's so good i
reckon we can aim for that but yeah um
so we have quite a few predictions to go
through so let's see your best one first
and then we can move on from there okay
so we're talking the calling game
and i'm very curious
you know how long this arc is going to
last because that also plays into you
know some of these predictions because
like
if it's not the final arc of the series
then
maybe some of this stuff might not
happen in it because that's that's just
ultimately what i'm curious about
because i know that gegay
is coming to the end of the series he
said like two years or something like
that did you hear about that man he
wants to wrap this up as soon as he can
like by the sounds of it um but yeah i
think
just my personal opinion i don't think
this is the final arc i think it's the
penalty mark i think there's one more
thing after this um after this stuff is
done i reckon sukun is going to be the
main threat in my opinion
yeah i agree with both points i i think
this is probably the penultimate arc
and that sukuna is the final villain but
um and just like i was just saying i
just maybe that's not the case not with
sukuna but just with maybe this is the
last arc maybe it's like you know the
blood war arc and bleach and i know that
was like more of a saga or something but
some of the
that final part of the arc was like 100
chapters long same thing with uh naruto
actually
just like really long arcs to send off
the series but anyway that brings me to
the first thing
and that is sukuna does the in chain
and takes over yuji that moment finally
happens
yeah yeah i had this one done as well
like you can't not have this um but go
on let's see your reasoning so he does
he says in chain takes over yuji
and it's double significant because
first of all you know he's doing it so
that's like a huge moment but now he's
in the culling game while he's doing it
so he starts making rules
as yuji
in the calling game like i don't know he
just does something and kills like a
thousand people or something and just
makes like 10 rule changes instantly
there's so many things that he could do
that would benefit himself
and also probably screw over kanjaku in
the process too
i don't think they're like enemies like
that though i feel like maybe tsukuno
could actually use kenjaku's plantae's
advantage in some way
i mean that's that's what i was gonna
say i mean at first it seems like
they are like pseudo allies at the
minimum
but also you know i get the feeling that
sucuna is like one of those guys that's
like you know no one is like really my
friend and it's ultimately you know me
versus the world
but yeah in terms of like the rules he
would make one thing i was thinking that
i had written down was that any rule he
would create is like
almost tailored to magumi because
obviously we all know he has a plan for
megumi right if he does make a rule
whatever he has planned for magoomy he
will tie into that and make that happen
and i guess the ultimate goal is for him
to get his physical body back using that
using mugumi in some way
sukuna is basically waiting for magumi
to unlock his full power or just unlock
a certain
ability that he may or may not have i
think he's waiting for that moment so
that he can take
magumi's curse technique from him
because that's like
i think they're going to be the big
twist about sakuna is that he has
multiple curse techniques i get that
because i mean he had that fire thing
which i don't even know what the hell
how he got that so i can definitely see
him stealing it i don't know how it
works maybe he maybe he's like uta
though and that he has like so much
curse energy that he can copy whatever
he wants to maybe
a kotu copies
curse techniques just by
i guess being your presence i don't know
if you ever saw that show heroes from
like 10 years ago no 20 years ago
actually i've seen bits of it because my
girlfriend's obsessed with it uh so i
might know what you're about to say well
the main character if he just comes in
contact with you gains your ability and
i think that's like the same thing with
a co2 because it's never explicitly
stated
how he gained her ability it's just
we've seen him just be in the presence
of someone but with uh
sakuna it could be that he like eats you
what
okay yeah i know
shakuna
has like
allegedly
has like a mouth in his stomach you can
see like the outline of it and like what
appears to be a tongue like when you
look at him on the cover
so yeah i mean it's not like blatant but
it's it's something certainly there but
also i'm pretty sure that sekuna
just in general like the mythology of
him
uh he has like a mouth stomach or
there's like other i'm
fairly i should have came more prepared
but i didn't uh bring up my
uh research on this but i did see it
there's like cicuna mouths imagery stuff
so basically he eats you with his mouth
and then he gains your cursed technique
that way
yeah well on that topic actually so one
of my predictions was that um so megumi
has a step sister and you know every
time we heard about her you know we've
heard how close they are and you know
how much he cares about her so i feel
like with her participating in the
cullen games sukuna could uh if tsumiki
is dying sukuna could offer yuji some
kind of binding vowel maybe and you know
in return he could save her life but
magumi has to give up his kind technique
willingly so it's not even like he's
stealing it's like i will give this to
you to save her kind of thing um i
thought that was a possibility moving on
to my next prediction so we both know
there's going to be a crap ton of deaths
in this thing especially as the whole
purpose of the cutting games is for
people to kill each other so it's
guaranteed to happen so one of the
deaths that i'm pretty sure about is
hikari now this guy was recently like
properly introduced a few well in the
last chapter actually um so we've just
got to know him and
he is giving me serious knowledge vibes
because he's super strong like youtube
seems to think really highly of him and
he just seems like the type of character
who is going to come on board with the
team going to be super strong going to
do some awesome stuff and he's going to
die you know he's just he's just giving
me those vibes because i feel like as
brave as gege is we're killing off
characters he's not going to kill off
utah i don't think he's not going to
kill fuji he's not going to kill megumi
i feel like kokari is just in that right
sweet spot the same way that noah was
where you can actually just kill him um
so kokari is the character that i am uh
99.99 sure he's not making out the
cullen games live
wow that's a super
super bold prediction after his
introduction chapter
see i kind of felt the opposite
i thought that if somebody was going to
die here is going to be a kotsu but you
seem to think that that's not an option
no i don't think so this world that
godzilla's trying to build right with
all these um
you know he's trying to build the next
generation of people who can surpass him
and take his place when you know
whenever he's whenever he's dead and i
feel like akotsu is at the front of that
right like that next generation you need
a coaster he's basically like almost
like an mc right um so i feel like he
has that mc plot armor even though he's
technically not the main character but i
feel like he still has that veil of
protection that would uh stop him from
being killed
maybe he gets a serious injury but i
mean then again he has reverse cast
technique so i'm sure he'll be fine
i mean as we've seen in the series
it's not like
everybody's safe and that's another
thing that i like about it is that not
everybody's safe
no no offense against
you know my hero
or uh one piece or you know the other
top series but
you know death isn't
always guaranteed uh sometimes
you know you kind of go into an arc with
this like sense of security i'll say i
mean i kind of feel that all the way uh
all the time
with uh my hero
but with jiu jitsu chryson that's not
necessarily the case
that being said i still do think there
are certain just a small handful who
were just a little bit protected um with
you know the ones i said earlier being
uh being among them um but someone who
is not in that is chozo
chozo is someone beside takari he's
another character i'm fairly certain
he's gonna die and i actually have a
pretty decent idea of how it's gonna
happen we already know that he's one of
the two people protecting tangent at the
moment and
that kind of invites at some point that
kinjaku will arrive right and so when
can jakku comes face to face with these
guys
chozo is by default the weakest person
there if they all fight
charles is probably gone i mean i'm
pretty sure he nearly died in shibuya
anyway so yeah i reckon he's gonna die
probably not gonna get to see um yuji
again before he dies
um but yeah gonna be a really sad scene
i bet that's
i think that's a perfect candidate
actually you nailed it on the head yeah
cho so
now that i think about it it's perfect
yeah he for sure
is going to die because he's like
you know he's right at that level of
importance where like anonymity was you
know and uh the audience loves him now
yeah so yeah perfect time
now last person i had that i'm pretty
sure is gonna die panda don't if you
agree with this one oh no but you don't
think so
i feel after after the whole chapter
that just we had with um
masavichi dying
well that's the thing so like
his death
who does panda have left now you know
what i mean like he has his friends yeah
friends [ __ ] yes friendship i mean the
power of friendship in this series can
only get you so far because we saw what
happened to nobara so i feel like it's
true let's play this way if there was
ever a scenario where someone has to
sacrifice himself who's gonna who's
gonna put their hand up it's probably
gonna be him because like i said he has
nothing really left besides his friends
so i think he would die for them
yeah i mean yeah i agree panda is
certainly a candidate
it would just suck because like god damn
he had such a hard life not so great a
year for him not so great
but uh let's see your next prediction so
uh go joe breaking out of the prison run
i don't know actually because uh it all
kind of relies on that uh what was her
name again the angel girl the one with
the power to nullify curse techniques
like uh hana kurusu exactly um we don't
know what her personality is like yeah i
don't know if she'd be willing to help
them i don't know why do you think he
definitely will come out
well because it was set up like for two
chapters like before or the either at
the beginning of the arc or right before
it started so
i'm assuming that's got to be one of the
elements of it and then also you know
she's a participant within the game the
the one person that they actually need
yeah you're totally right it is being
set up for sure like they're gonna try
um the one thing i
wonder though you know because gojo is
so opie there was one panel where megumi
was like if gojo was free he'd sort this
all out in 30 seconds so i feel like
gage on purpose would probably
keep him locked away for as long as
possible because in this time that he's
away
it's the perfect time to flesh out
everyone else and make everyone else
fight this battle you know what i mean
oh yeah for sure
if he does come out this arc it will
literally be like probably the last
thing that happens before we move on to
the next one
but i was also thinking that maybe when
he comes out that's when sukuna
has like fully revived or something yeah
because that fight was forced out of
pretty much from day one right it's
foreshadowed actually like two or three
times it's foreshadowed the very
beginning and then there's another i
made a video about it but i forget the
exact things i talked about
but yeah um
i i think it's going to definitely
happen like gage talks about it
and i don't think it's like a throwaway
thing
how would you see that going to be fat
like
i think shakuna has to win
not because necessarily he's stronger or
power scaling or whatever about i'm just
talking narrative wise
i think sukuna
he has to win that to establish that
he's pretty much unbeatable like gojo
has built himself up the whole entire
series by people having having people
job to him
like losing in order to establish
somebody's power or dominance
and then it
ultimately leads to him being the
ultimate jobber because he
loses to sacuna and then it's like okay
so now not even gojo could take down the
big bad now we need the mcs to do it
what you just said it reminded me um of
the beginning of infinity war you
remember when like thanos just beat down
hulk oh my god it's iconic yeah beaten
down with no stones or anything just
bass thanos
bass sucuna
yeah so um one prediction i had uh about
sukuna this was foreshadowed early on as
well and that was the idea that yuji
will gain his curse technique um
sakuna's cursed technique because when
gojo was teaching yuji about you know
the idea of what that is there was this
one panel when gojo was like kind of
implying that yuji
will inherit the uh sukunisti basically
um so i feel like at some point in the
cullen games not only will we get more
explanation on yuji's false memories
ability but we will also see him also
like gaining a little bit of control
over sokuna's cleave and dismantle
abilities
possibly maybe towards the end mr kuna
you know gets his own body um but uh
yeah i feel like that's something that
should happen
i agree i actually forgot to bring that
up that's something that i
wrote or just mentally wrote down coming
into this because yeah i i do remember
gojo talking about that but that was
also a very long time ago
and uh it's definitely gonna pay off for
sure but just like when is that i guess
it's gotta be
soon like maybe in like the next like
big fight that happens within the
calling game
we might see yuji eventually uh tap into
that what if he kills someone in fact
because we all know how yuji feels about
like killing people if he did that by
accident killed someone i reckon that'll
be pretty funny reaction from him i
think that he will i think that there's
going to be at least one casualty like
human person that he kills uh maybe
because it's like an accident or he's
like absolutely forced to do it
yeah did you have any more predictions
no that's pretty much it okay so last
one to mention magumi will finally
master his domain expansion on the third
time lucky because we've seen him do it
twice now in the manga where he's
partially manifested it but not quite um
and i think we could have a gentle
little barber situation where sakumi's
sorry sumiki's kirstenig whatever it may
be
that might actually help megumi to
finally master the domain expansion what
do you think about that that's brilliant
actually i always thought that
tsumiki's curse technique was
i don't know going to be some
detrimental for some reason like it was
going to be something that she couldn't
control i don't know why i felt this way
just i kind of was getting that
impression that
they were gonna have to inadvertently
fight her for some reason but if it's
like the other way
and that it complements magumi and
actually unlocks the full chimera shadow
garden
that would be really cool actually what
do you think a full
100
chimera shadow garden could be i feel
like we saw how uh he was able to
duplicate himself and also duplicate the
shikigami right and that's only with the
partial domain so i feel like with the
full thing he could make unlimited
copies of himself unlimited copies of
shikigami um from the shadows and
i guess if i i'm not sure if you would
have had maharaga by that point you know
he will get it eventually but uh if he
does have maharaga could you imagine if
he made like 10 maharagas and just you
know whoever he's got in there just
attacks them with that i mean that's
perfect actually because that would be
i mean i assume this is happening in the
final arc like when he has just like an
army of maharagas in his domain because
that would be very fitting for like the
deuteragonist's final power up you know
this is like his renagon with the
magneco
um
spiritual uh giant thing i forget the
name
if you know naruto but yeah uh the army
of maharagas that just sounds
awesome
almost too good to be true actually
why not you know especially like you say
if it's the final final arc
to help with it you can do whatever you
want right so um yeah i looking forward
to it but uh yeah with that said thank
you for coming on the channel and for
anyone watching this video be sure to
check out shonen's channel because uh he
does uh jjk
chapter reviews every week you do other
videos as well right
yeah something like that
thanks for watching guys and until the
next one peace out